if you were looking forward to playing
far cry 5 or the crew - you'll have to
wait a bit longer now I'm Tony and this
GameSpot news update is being pushed
back far cry 5 has been delayed Ubisoft
announced a new release date of March
27th 2018 which is one month later than
planned
additionally the crew twos March release
date has been changed to the first half
of Ubisoft
2018 to 19 fiscal year meaning it'll
launch sometime between April and
September 2018 the publisher also
announced a delay for a new game and an
existing franchise that hasn't even been
revealed yet but whatever it is it's
been moved to sometime between April
2019 and March 20 20 Ubisoft reason for
these delays is for quote investing more
time in the development of these games
the publisher cites the extended
development cycle of Assassin's Creed
origins as an example saying it was
beneficial to that game overall and for
reference origins did receive a positive
seven out of ten from GameSpot but to
see how it stacks up against other 2017
games tune in as we begin our game of
the year countdown next week
[Music]